[Aplausos]
numa sociedade em que a voz que
predomina é a voz do homem adulto branco
o homem intelectual o que significa
colocar literatura na mão dos
trabalhadores e das trabalhadoras e dos
seus filhos o que acontece quando
trabalhadores trocam as suas ferramentas
de trabalho por livros por literatura
vale a pena investir em levar literatura
de qualidade pra áreas em que as pessoas
têm necessidades materiais
essas são perguntas que eu não me fiz
aos 18 anos quando pensei em entrar numa
universidade terceira filha de um casal
de imigrantes nordestinos ea primeira
pessoa fazer uma faculdade na minha
família e eu queria fazer uma faculdade
de verdade e nos anos 80 faculdade de
verdade estava ligado ou ao direito ou a
medicina ou as ciências exatas
então a menina magrinha tímida pouco em
poder ada que fazer matemática que
pudesse ser uma ciência da verdade uma
ciência da exatidão e que pudesse dessa
forma me conferir mais visibilidade mais
respeito
eu achava que na faculdade eu ia poder
discutir porque na vida nós tirávamos 10
e na escola a matemática é uma ciência
aaas
temida uma ciência do fracasso porque 10
na vida e 0 na escola infelizmente essa
não foi a discussão feita naquele espaço
eu fiz a faculdade e nesse mesmo tempo
estou falando dos anos 80 eu encontrei
os poetas negros os escritores negros
que começaram a falar pra mim de uma
outra exatidão de uma outra
possibilidade de ser 10 na vida um poeta
particularmente marcou a minha história
e meu corpo
oliveira silveira tem um poema que diz
querem que a gente saiba que nós fomos
escravos e que eles são senhores
eles foram senhores e nós fomos escravos
eu disse fomos esse poema de oliveira
silveira foi tão marcante pra mim que me
trouxe uma voz que eu não tinha me
trouxe uma voz de reconhecimento essa
voz grave
eu descobri depois dos 18 anos
essa possibilidade de mudar uma história
que parecia que estava dada
esse aqui não era tão bom pra mim
poderia ser também bom pra outras
pessoas
se aquela literatura aquela palavra que
transformava o meu corpo e meu lugar no
mundo
ela poderia também ser importante
essencial para outras pessoas
e aí virou quase uma obsessão levar
livros e literatura cruz vários lugares
da cidade possibilitar que mulheres
conhecessem biografias como a de frida
kahlo de carolina maria de jesus e
outras palavras
para que pudessem também dar um novo
lugar para os seus corpos ea obsessão
foi tão grande que além de levar
literatura e bibliotecas comunitárias
para a área de saúde para equipamentos
de comércio nós chegamos a um cemitério
ac no extremo sul da cidade de são paulo
num primeiro cemitério foi construído
nessa cidade em parelheiros
nós temos uma biblioteca quando nós
fizemos a proposta de criar a primeira
biblioteca daquela região
naquele lugar que era a casa do coveiro
alguns jovens falar mas nem morto e foi
morto tem que ir precise vivo precisa
ser vivo e levar palavras que possam
gerar vida e nesse espaço do cemitério
na casa do coveiro nós lemos alta
literatura e os jovens descobriram que
gostavam de ler não imaginavam que ler
poderia ser tão em poder a dor que ler
poderia dar a possibilidade de voar e
transpor o destino dado ciências exatas
se economia
se a profissão poderiam nos ajudar a
pensar o dia-a-dia a literatura ajudava
a voar para além do disco do destino
dado a ajudava a voar para o futuro e
essa descoberta tem feito com que essa
biblioteca do cemitério ela vá além dos
túmulos
esses jovens levam literatura para as
ruas que levam à literatura para as
praças e além disso começaram a
descobrir que eles podem escrever uma
biblioteca é um lugar para se ler
histórias e também pra ser guardiã das
histórias e das memórias de uma
comunidade
jovens têm começado a escrever sobre
suas histórias e sobre as suas
percepções uma das experiências que tem
acontecido aqui no estado de são paulo é
o prêmio a cone de promoção da igualdade
racial em que crianças e jovens a partir
da literatura têm começado a escrever
suas histórias e uma outra experiência
do líder a sampa que foi chamada de me
vejo no que vejo a poesia de ser quem
sou porque quando a gente começa a ler
personagens que se parecem com a gente
a gente acredita que a nossa história
pode ser contada e aí eu vou trazer aqui
duas histórias escritas por crianças
uma é a história da samara ela escreveu
essa história em quadrinhos para o
prêmio a cone que significa coragem ela
chega numa loja de brinquedos
olha todas as bonecas que estão lá
dispostas e ela pede para a vendedora eu
queria uma boneca mais linda do que eu
uma boneca negra que se pareça comigo aí
é vendedora pede desculpas fala olha
aqui a gente não trabalha com esse tipo
de boneca lá não era uma loja de bonecas
étnicas porque tentam colocar né os
negros num determinado setor
e ela fala mas não é possível que com
tantas bonecas aqui vocês não têm uma
boneca que se pareça comigo e começa a
gritar
a mãe chega e fala filha que escândalo
que está acontecendo aqui
ela fala com esse monte de brinquedo não
tem uma boneca que se pareça comigo a
mãe fala filha o preconceito de cor
alcançou até o mercado dos brinquedos
vamos embora e ela fala não eu vou levar
essa mesmo quando nós adultos vimos essa
história nós ficamos um pouco
desanimados
nós falamos que a gente está fazendo que
as crianças tão pequena
uma menina de 11 anos desistindo e se
conformando e aí alguém
um dos especialistas chamou a atenção
pro último quadrinho em que ela tinha lá
as bolinhas do pensamento não é a
característica gráfica da história em
quadrinhos e aí no pensamento aparecia
lá com um pincel pintando a boneca de
preto
então não era uma resignação era um
protesto eu levo essa mesma e eu vou
transformá la num outro uma outra
história
são três crianças brincando na escola e
elas uma delas fala assim vamos brincar
brincar de casinha duas crianças brancas
e uma criança negra a primeira criança
branca fala eu vou ser mamãe
a outra rapidamente e você a filhinha ea
menina negra fale eu aí uma fala você
pode ser empregada nas novelas sempre as
negras são empregadas
ela responde ah não eu não quero ser
empregada
as outras duas mas você vai ser o que
então você a doutora da família e aí uma
delas fala mas eu nunca vi uma doutora
negra agora você vai ver a primeira
então as crianças elas estão dizendo pra
gente quando ela se apropriam quando
elas se vêem elas vão dizendo pra gente
esse mundo é possível e uma menina de 9
anos outra de 11 anos conseguiram mais
cedo por esse poder da literatura das
imagens e das palavras fazer um caminho
que abel só conseguiu aos 18 anos o que
essas meninas estão fazendo lendo essas
histórias
seguido que carolina maria de jesus
uma catadora de materiais recicláveis
aqui da cidade de são paulo que não
abriu mão do direito de contar a sua
história do direito a fabulação do
direito à fantasia do direito a metáfora
do direito à leitura da sua própria vida
disse pra nós e um dos seus trechos num
livro que ela chamou de quarto de
despejo carolina nos disse uma palavra
escrita não pode ser apagada por mais
que o desenho tenha sido feito a lápis e
que seja de boa qualidade a borracha
o papel vai sempre guardar o relevo das
letras escritas não senhor
ninguém pode apagar as palavras que eu
escrevi as histórias que esses filhos de
trabalhadores que essas mulheres têm
feito substituindo as suas ferramentas
de trabalho por livros e por leituras
essa história não vai ser apagada por
ninguém
essa história tá aí nas casas nos
cemitérios nessa cidade
obrigada
[Aplausos]